CENTER ICE -- NTO
THE SAMUELSSON OUT
THERE, A
THEY SCORE!
KYLE OKPOSO WAS THERE TO
BELOW THE GOAL LINE.
THE SIDE FROM BEAUVILLIER, YOU
CAN SEE SOON ASIT, CHECK THAT
IT'S PEYTON KREBS, HE TOOK DOBS.
BARZAL --
ON THE REBOUND
THEYTUNITY THAT WAS
BLOCKED, THOMPSON STAYS WITH WA
SABRES ABLE TO EXIT THE ZONE F S
GAME.
>> Rob: RIGHT OFF THE FACEOFF,
THE ISLANDERS ARE GOING TO GET A
CHANCE HER --
CHARA
LINE, BUFFALO STILL CAN'T GET IT
OUT, ISLANDERS KEEPING IT
THE SHOT.
REFLECTED OFF INTO THE DEFLECT .
TOKARSKI MADE THE SAVE.
WHERE'S THE PUCK.RAIGHT TO THE .
OKPOSO.
WHEELS IT BACKKREBS, HE SCOOORE
WANT TO TELL YOU IT'S IN THE
NICK OF TIME!!E, IT'S IN THESSO
SLAPPED AT IT AGAIN, DIDN'T GET
IT OUT, AND IT'
>> Rob: YEAH IN THE BLUE LINE IS
NOT THE SPOT YOU WANT TO TURN
THE PUCK OAND NOT OUT
OF THE ZONE THOUGH.
ISLANDERS
GETTING A LITTLE BIT MORE BODY
PRESENCE IN FRONT OF THE NET,
GOING TO IN BEHIND THE
NET, WITH A SHOT, THEY SCORE,TO.
KREBS GOT IT OUT IN FRONT, T
I'LL TELL YOU,S THIS A SMILE ON
HIS FACE.
>> Rick: I'LL BET YOU.
>> Rob::AGAIN.
THEN THIS LONG SHOT, HE
HENRI JOKIHARJU SEEN THE LANE
AND THEN COUPLE BLOCK THERE'D,
WING TO CENTER
ICE.
AND
>> Rob: VICTOR OLOFSSON